[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle sûr et j'ai 15 ans
et mon amie carole à trésors elle est
beaucoup plus grande que moi c'est pas
juste ce qui m'embête dans la vie c'est
que je suis petit
je mesure combien un mètre quarante six
raconte moi un peu ce qui se passe on me
dit demi portions qui n'a
puis on laisse de côté ne dissipe pas de
ton âge que c'était un enfer entre en
sixième les grands me tirait les cheveux
et puissent s'amuser parce que j'étais
petit
alors tu es obligé de réagir ben oui
mais qu'est ce que tu fais dans ces cas
là
bas je les pousse puis je coure
politiques matap une fois j'étais avec
mon père et mes parents des amis et on a
été voir un film c'est l arme fatale
et le cinéma n'a pas voulu me laisser
rentrer et j'étais avec mes parents et
j'ai oublié ma carte d'identité mais
j'avais 14 ans et j'ai été voir un autre
film à la place
c'est à dire que des films de moins de
13 ans ne laisse pas rentrer si j'ai pas
ma carte si j'ai une mobylette un jour à
ba je pourrais pas parce que je fais
tout le temps d'arrêter par la police
parce que je suis trop petit et puis
c'est pas la peine je m'habille 1 13 ans
et demi 14 mais je suis obligé de faire
des très grands mais
autrement tu flottes tran huy je flotte
mais autre inconvénient son camp je fais
du foot ben quand je veux où gaulle et
buy me love facilement
pour la gym pour attraper la barre fixe
ça c'est dur parce qu'elle est assez
haute est ce que tu es le seul petit
lampe à glace non il y en a un plus
petit mois mais lui c'est normal lui les
plus jeunes il y a que 13 ans moi c'est
pas pareil chez moi je manque d'hormones
de croissance et il faut me donner avec
des piqûres qu'on fait tous les jours et
j'ai des semaines de 4 des semaines de
5,8
[Applaudissements]
et depuis que tu fais ton traitement ça
fait une différence
je mange beaucoup plus
[Musique]
et j'ai grossi un petit peu
ça fait quelque chose alors tu as grandi
de combien depuis que tu as commencé pas
beaucoup je sais pas peut-être d'un
centimètre sat inquiète beaucoup
un petit peu et ça m'inquiète il mesure
keita était parent telle mesure 1 mètre
80 et ma mère à m 62 et il ya d'autres
gens petit dans ta famille oui ma grand
mère et ma tante
toi si tu avais une taille idéale ce
serait quoi elle mettait
sa taille de ton papa ça oui le peu près
pareil écran quand même cv quel âge la
boudeuse les grands l'intention d'avoir
14 ans le 13 octobre et
alors toi tu mesure combien 1 m 84
et toi moi je veux faire un mètre 75 ans
lyon cédric au mieux à votre avis là
quel âge
[Musique]
non plus quand même peut-être remarqué
dans les dix plus petit que cédric tu en
connais way qui ont 15 ans voilà ils
mesurent combien à m 44 les hauts postes
supprimés pour moi je construis souviens
tu as quel âge deux ans et demi et une
mesure combien américain de 17 que je
prends pas qu'on peut être complexé
parce qu'on est une petite les autres et
vice versa 14 et une mesure trop bien
avec 50 si tu étais petit wassat
embêterait
si tu as des copains de sa taille de sa
taille oui j'en ai ils ont quel âge
il y en a je peux ferait également chez
les garçons petit tour au nom
[Musique]